[Music]
yes
all right
what is your opinion
on the vaccine
i have no opinion
i'll tell you what the church's official
position is you must make an individual
choice
based on praying to god for guidance
following the health laws the counselors
of ellen white and then making your
individual decision
that's the position of the church and i
am no position to go against the church
because i see nothing sinful about that
counsel
make your individual decision remember
psalm 32 verse 8 i will instruct thee
and teach thee in the way which thou
shalt go psalm 25 verse 4 show me thy
ways o lord teach me thy paths james 1
verse 5 if any of you lack wisdom let
him ask of god that given to all men
liberally jeremiah 33 verse 3 call unto
me and i will answer thee and show the
great and mighty things which thou
knowest ask god should i take the
vaccine
he will convict you one way or the other
because your body belongs to him
amen
all right